[Music]
[Applause]
hello I'm Xena but are we welcome to
this intelligence squared debate here in
Cadogan Hall in London when we'll be
debating whether the West should loosen
its ties with Saudi Arabia when King
Abdullah died in January Western leaders
flocked to his funeral a clear sign that
they saw the House of Saud as a key ally
in a turbulent region where extremists a
gaining ground yet Saudi Arabia is a
conservative society look at its
treatment of women it's public
beheadings its floggings and of course
its export of puritanical religious
beliefs and this has led others to say
it is time to end this decades-long
alliance with Riyadh so our motion today
is the West should get out of bed with
the House of Saud and we have an
excellent panel for you we have arguing
for the motion Mona Eltahawy Egyptian
American journalist and human rights
campaigner also Hillary man Leverett
u.s. foreign policy expert and former
career diplomat arguing against the
motion
James Rubin former US State Department
official and British Conservative MPs
Alan Duncan who until last year was
Minister of State for international
development that is our panel welcome to
you all
in a moment we're going to hear our four
speakers present their arguments to you
and then we're going to have the debate
open to the floor now as our audience
was coming into Cadogan Hall we actually
polled our audience to see where they
stand on the motion I'll be bringing you
that result after we've heard our
speakers and then our audience will also
be asked to vote again at the end of the
debate to see if any opinions have
shifted and whether that's had an impact
on the result but first of all we're
going to have our opening statement from
the panelists and speaking first for the
motion Mona Eltahawy now she writes and
provides commentary on Egypt the Islamic
world and women's rights she was named
by Newsweek magazine as one of its 150
fearless women of 2012
I know Mona and boy does she deserve
that title Mona lives in Cairo and New
York
good evening everyone I'm very glad to
be here and I look forward to a
rollicking debate in January 10 days
before the Saudi King Abdullah died a
woman from Burma was dragged to a public
square in Mecca the holiest site for
Muslims she was held down by four saudi
policemen as she screamed I did not kill
I did not kill after which an
executioner took three blows to behead
her this woman at the time was just the
tenth person to be executed in Saudi
Arabia but now under the reign of King
Salman that number is up to 88 and that
number outnumbers the number of people
that Saudi Arabia executed last year now
Saudi Arabia is in illustrious company
including that of the United States of
course because along with three other
countries they're in the top five of the
countries that execute people now I
oppose the death penalty everywhere
but especially in a country like Saudi
Arabia where human rights groups have
long documented the injustice under
which people are beheaded most of the
people who've been executed in Saudi
Arabia this year have been either Saudis
or people from poor countries such as
Bangladesh Sri Lanka and other
developing countries human rights groups
have made it very clear that the so
called trials after which these people
are beheaded in public squares are done
often with no legal representation are
often conducted in arabic a language
that most of the people on trial do not
understand and often those people are
forced to sign confessions again in
arabic that they don't understand
you often hear the Saudi royal family
used the term exceptionalism that Saudi
Arabia is different than other countries
and that the Saudi royal family will
help the people develop and progress
because of this exceptional atmosphere
in reality it's the Saudi royal family
that is exceptional exceptional in its
brutality exceptional in its
dictatorship and exceptional in its
gender apartheid I'm a proud Muslim and
in Islam that is practiced in Saudi
Arabia is unlikely
Selam practiced anywhere else including
my country of birth Egypt in Saudi
Arabia there are more women than men on
university campuses they recognize the
value of knowledge but what do women do
after they get this knowledge on their
campuses what happens to them in this
exception and environment they basically
have to go home and watch men who are
much less qualified than they are get
jobs that they cannot have Saudi Arabia
is a country again or remind you that
says it's exceptional and needs to
develop slowly if it was so exceptional
why are all those activists that you
rarely hear about out there fighting to
prove that they are ready for freedom
have you heard of right if Bedouin a
blogger who was sentenced to ten years
in jail and 1,000 lashes his crime he
set up a website for Saudi liberals and
there to question the version of Islam
that the Saudi royal family promotes as
the true Islam this is Saudi Arabia and
you will know in this country what it is
that keeps the West in bed with the
Saudi regime it is basically money oil
and weapons this country has a long
history of selling weapons to the Saudis
and you will remember that al Yamamah
scandal in which BAE sold billions of
pounds of weapons to Saudi Arabia that
enriched arms manufacturers in this
country and enriched Saudi princes in
one of the biggest corruption scandals
that was broken by the the UK media here
Canada a country that often likes to
boast has a progressive record whether
it comes to women's rights or human
rights generally is currently embroiled
in its own weapons scandal because
although Canadian the Canadian
government policy forbids the government
from selling weapons to countries that
violate human rights the Canadian
government just brokered a deal worth
fifteen million dollars to sell armored
personnel carriers to Saudi Arabia who
do you think the Saudis used those
weapons against when they're not bombing
Yemeni civilians they're using those
weapons against their own population
again those peaceful activists who are
trying to be free and to give the lie to
this idea that the Saudi Arabian
experience of dictatorship is somehow
exceptional so weapons weapons deals
oil
the hypocrisy of the West a story that
you hear over and over and yet the West
refuses to get out of bed with the Saudi
royal family perhaps it's ironic but it
speaks volumes to that hypocrisy that
the truest thing said about the Saudis
from the US administration was in a
fictional show called West Wing which
many of you might have seen you might
remember CJ Cregg the White House
spokesperson who pushed to give a
comment about the burning to death of
those schoolgirls at first said I don't
have anything to say and push the
comment again she was asked are you
outraged she listed a whole list of
crimes that the Saudi regime commits but
she very honestly wrapped it up as I
will now wrap it up by saying Saudi
Arabia our partners in peace fully
recognizing that hypocrisy I would add
to that Saudi Arabia the partner of the
West in peace hypocrisy and blood money
thank you
Thank You Mona Eltahawy now speaking
against the motion
James Ruben he served under President
Clinton as Assistant Secretary of State
for public affairs and was chief
spokesman for the Secretary of State
Madeleine Albright and he writes a
regular column for the British newspaper
The Sunday Times Thank You Mona
presented a an elaborate series of
charges all of which I assume to be
accurate and all of which are outrageous
but that doesn't get to the question
this house has been asked to debate to
get out of bed you have to be in bed I
don't believe the United States is any
longer in bed with the Saudi government
first of all obviously Americans
recognize that a lot of Saudi citizens
were responsible for 9/11 the Saudi
government obviously funded Mohave ism
around the world and that outraged
Americans but more importantly since
this last 25 years have gone by the
United States on the right regards the
Saudi government as leaders of Islamic
fundamentalism on the Left regards
everything Mona said is true and so
there is not a very comfortable
relationship on the american side but
what's even more interesting is the
Saudi side Saudi Arabia doesn't think
America's its partner anymore and that
changed after the Iraq war when George W
Bush showed first of all that the Shiite
Iranian government was the big victor of
the Iraq war the Saudis hated that and
more importantly he showed how
incompetently the United States could
run a large military operation now we
have the Arab Spring and what did the
Saudis see the United States throw in
their opinion Mubarak under the bus they
were outraged by the way in which the
United States chose the side of the
people on the ground in Cairo rather
than
mubarak and they said that could be us
if things change here
they were seething with anger so in the
Saudi mine what's this security
guarantee worth if the country that's
doing the guaranteeing is unreliable but
if you are going to insist that despite
all this despite the huge changes in the
Saudi relationship with the United
States that we are somehow still in bed
look at the relationship with the
Iranian agreement the Saudi government
is so concerned that the United States
is going to tilt towards Iran that they
were opposing an arms control agreement
that's basically in their interest so
why would the Saudis be against it well
they're against it because they see Iran
on the March as a result of American
failures over and over I'm not agreeing
with this I'm giving you their
perspective look the Arab Spring was a
painful experience for those of us who
believe in human rights and making
changes in in promoting democracy very
painful but we've seen what happened
when the Arab Awakening occurred we have
seen the dangers we've seen the risks
and they are frightening we now have
what we said we would never have in the
world and a terrorist organization by
the name of Isis with a piece of real
estate the size of a large Arab state in
Iraq and Syria with places to plan to
organize and with the bloodthirstiness
we've never seen before
and we need help in combating it it's
the sad truth but as long as the United
States is limiting its involvement the
British the Europeans and other
countries we need help and that's why
they are one of many countries helping
in a coalition to fight Isis so these
are very real practical issues the real
winner I'm sorry to say of the Arab
Awakening at least for the moment was
the extremist Islamic groups well you
put all this together and what you find
is that the world has changed those of
us who supported most the use of force
for democratic values are on our heels
because there is a dangerous cancer
growing in that part of the world in the
form of Isis and other extremist groups
we have to deal with that we have to
defeat that and then we can get back to
berating Arab governments for their
democratic failings we they're not in
bed so we can't get out of bed or if we
are in bed in this form let's face it we
need to do what we need to do right now
thank you
Thank You Jaime Ruben thank you very
much now our second speaker for the
motion and let me just remind what the
motion is the West should get out of bed
with the House of Saud Hillary man
Leverett she served at the White House
in both the Clinton and George W Bush
administration's and she advocates us
rapprochement with Iran and is the
co-author of going to Tehran you're
going to be going to the lectern now
those who make your arguments thank you
thank you ladies and gentlemen I started
working for the u.s. Department of State
back in 1990 at a high point in u.s.
Saudi and Western Saudi relations when
our militaries came together to liberate
Kuwait after Saddam Hussein's Iraq
invaded after 25 years including
multiple assignments and US embassies
across the Middle East and working in
both Democratic and Republican White
House's
I have come to believe it imperative for
the West to get out of bed with the
House of Saud I take this position
because it is delusional to think that
the security and financial benefits of
collaborating with the Saudis serve
Western interests instead the so-called
security and financial benefits of
collaborating with Saudi Arabia need to
be seen for what they are dangerous
enablers of a deeply self damaging
Western strategy toward the Middle East
a strategy largely responsible for the
dramatic decline in America's
international standings since the end of
the Cold War and an even faster clip
since 9/11 perpetuated long enough this
strategy will destroy America's status
as a great power dragging the West down
with it first some argue that Saudi
collaboration has been and remains
essential to projecting Western
especially u.s. power in the Middle East
but this willfully overlooks how such
power projection actually works to
destabilize the Middle East and
undermine Western interests an extremely
pernicious
example of this dates back to July 1979
when the Carter Administration joined
with Saudi Arabia to arm fund and train
jihadi militants in Afghanistan before
the Soviet invasion many of these same
jihadi militants turned their venom on
the West killing thousands on 9/11
nevertheless the West repeatedly
succumbs to this day to the temptation
of collaborating with Saudi Arabia to
empower ever more jihadi militants in
Iraq in Libya in Syria in Yemen against
actors the West doesn't like each time
the West tells itself it derives
short-term benefit from harming our
designated adversary given this record
any claim that Saudi Arabia is now a
partner in fighting jihadi groups is
absurd these groups literally would not
exist but for Saudi Arabia and it will
not be the Saudis who help us defeat
them another pernicious form of Saudi
enabled Western power projection is
Saudi support for the deployment of
hundreds of thousands of US and Western
troops to the Middle East over the past
quarter century the vast majority of
Muslim public's in the Middle East now
overwhelmingly see America and its
partners as the biggest threat to their
security and welfare this is clearly a
losing proposition for the West
some argue that Saudi collaboration is
essential to roll back Iran's rising
regional influence again it is
delusional to think that that actually
will advance Western interests in
reality Western collaboration with Saudi
Arabia against Iran is fueling
potentially genocidal mainly anti-shia
violence in the Middle East at this
point the West cannot achieve any of its
stated goals in Iraq in Syria in Yemen
on Afghanistan Afghanistan on terrorism
on proliferation on energy security
without productive
full-range relations with the Islamic
Republic of Iran
some argue that Saudi collaboration is
essential to secure stable oil flows
from the Persian Gulf to international
energy markets the oil market also rests
on an assumption that the House of Saud
will remain stable II in power
indefinitely while some tout the smooth
succession from Saudi King Abdullah to
King Salman earlier this year in fact
Salman and his coterie have changed the
upper levels of Saudi political
leadership more radically than at any
point in Saudi history by doing so they
have created dangerously high risks of
intra family conflict conflict that is
likely to lead to the fragmentation of
the Saudi state with devastating
consequences for stability on the
Arabian Peninsula it is imperative that
the West not wait for a popular
revolution in Saudi Arabia with all the
economic chaos and calamities that would
come with it at this juncture the West's
position in the Middle East is in
freefall
staying in bed with the House of Saud
only guarantees the West's irrevocable
strategic failure in the Middle East and
around the world thank you
[Applause]
hilary thank you and our second speaker
against the motion is the senior
conservative MP here sir alan Duncan he
was Minister of State for international
development until last year and is a
leading voice in the UK on the Middle
East where he travels regularly ladies
and gentlemen the fundamental assumption
of this motion is that you can sit
comfortably in your armchair judge your
country or as one that's not up to your
standards wag your finger and then break
with that country and think that you
have somehow created a better world well
I think nothing could be further from
the truth and I'd like to put it to you
bluntly that the proposers of this
motion misunderstand the nature of
foreign policy they miss read the
current situation in Saudi Arabia itself
and the Middle East more widely and they
misjudge how dangerous their proposed
course of action would be so there are
things in the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
that none of us like and where I would
agree with Mona and Hillary I don't like
judicial beheading
I don't like treating women as
second-class citizens I actually don't
like a lot of the vulgar opulence and
the extremes of inequality and it's
because of those elements in most of the
arguments we've heard that this motion
suggests that we face a choice and that
we should decide between practical
friendship on the one hand and
disapproval and even divorce on the
other such a simplistic choice is not
how foreign policy does work and it's
not how foreign policy should work so I
think it's if I can be blunt facile and
foolhardy to look at Saudi Arabia
conclude that there are aspects of the
country we
round upon which we do and then resolve
to put them in the naughty corner I
think that such a simple judgmental view
both misunderstands the kingdom as it is
and even worse it catastrophic Allah
fails to appreciate the consequences
that would follow a decision to
ostracize them so first let's look at
Saudi Arabia as it is and here I would
suggest is the real weakness and paradox
of the proposition something very
important needs to be understood here
the Al Saud the ruling family those who
this motion wishes to condemn are
actually more progressive more liberal
and more enlightened than many of the
people who they govern its many of the
people much more than they all sound
from selves who are hardline in their
views and you cannot blame everything
you dislike in the country on those who
rule it so it's not the old souds who
are financing Isis or - whatever you
want to call it some people within Saudi
Arabia almost certainly have done so but
not the government indeed the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia is now in the forefront of
resisting Isis and Al Qaeda and without
the ourselves Saudi Arabia would not be
doing that at all we need the state we
need that Kingdom to hold sway over
non-state actors threatening the region
if they were to be shunned by the West
there would be a serious reaction
internally it would be wholly
counterproductive it would provoke and
empower the extremists in their midst
it would not free up what is good it
would accentuate what is bad and what if
the else Albert ooh be displaced all
together it would unleash a catastrophe
of extremism disorder and uncertainty
and that is what inheritable ii fills a
power vacuum now the Arab Spring has
proved beyond all doubt the value of
stability over chaos no one should want
to see the pain of Syria Iraq or Libya
extend to the likes of Saudi Arabia or
their neighbors so ladies and gentlemen
foreign policy is not about
straightforward easy choices between
right and wrong good and bad in bed or
out of bed it's always about shades of
grey
you cannot just flick a switch and
create a liberal democracy overnight so
I think the movers of this motion are
being naive I think they're being
reckless I think they're being unwise so
I hope that all of you will join Jamie
and me in rejecting the dangerous plan
of action
thank you very much indeed silence so
there you have it you've heard our four
speakers - four - against the motion
give you their opening arguments now I
have very interesting pre-debate results
here which I'm going to give you before
we go to questions from the floor and
this was how they voted on our motion
the West should get out of bed with the
house of sound so agreeing with that
motion for the motion 43% against the
motion
17% 1 7 and the don't know 40% so that's
a very very interesting result there
because it means there's a great deal
for both sides to play for so now let us
go to the floor okay I would like to ask
them why now what's your definition of
democracy that you want to see in Saudi
Arabia because if you're talking about
Western democracy I don't think it will
apply in a traditional society like the
Saudi society if you're talking about
the behaving and chopping hands I think
this is part of the Sharia law which is
accepted and wanted by the Saudi people
so what's your definition of democracy
that you want the Saudi survive okay
thank you for that yes it's a shared
cubicles
former British ambassador I would say
ask the women of Saudi Arabia what they
want and they would want us as Alan
suggested that we take the world not as
we want it to be but it as it is and
they would want us to remain engaged
with Saudi Arabia in our own interests
in the interests of the people of Saudi
Arabia in the interests of Iran in the
interests of the whole region if you
want stability in the Middle East if you
want a bit better future for the people
of the Middle East then vote
is motion okay what's it so why don't we
get that response from you there Mona on
the definition of democracy that you
think would work for Saudi Arabia and
also the point about women in Saudi
Arabia want you to be engaged I used two
words in my presentations that I'm going
to repeat one was exceptionalism which
addresses what you're saying about how
Saudi Arabia has its own ways and they
must be respected and the other word
that I used was apartheid and I called
the way that women are treated in Saudi
Arabia gender apartheid and that word
apartheid should remind you of a country
that we also used the word apartheid
against and that was South Africa so
Sheridan and the Saudi women there in
the audience said the point is even if
you don't like the way women are treated
in Saudi Arabia that his point was you
want the West to engage still and Saudi
women want the West to engage with them
what has that engagement brought us Dana
that engagement has brought us very
little I gave you a catalogue of human
rights abuses and violations and in
answer to your question the Saudi woman
here
you asked me what's my definition of
democracy well my definition of
democracy is freedom and freedom doesn't
change according to where you are
freedom is about human rights freedom is
about equality freedom is a human right
thank you Hillary briefly if you would
[Applause]
in our commenter today put out a false
argument of course we should engage with
the Saudi government the problem is that
the West has focused its strategy on the
Middle East
artificially on propping up two
governments that are not representative
their populations the government of
Israel and the government of Saudi
Arabia both of them though there are
thousands of princes they don't
represent the Saudi population and
though of course there are millions of
Jews in Israel they don't represent the
majority of the people under Israeli
control that's why both Israel and Saudi
Arabia have turned to the United States
for military protection to prop up their
governments of course we should engage
with them like we should engage with all
countries with pork constructive
relations the problem in having these
skewed relations these special
relationships with the governments of
Israel and Saudi Arabia
that it shields them and enables them to
take to pursue policies that are
damaging to the West let's try and keep
to Saudi Arabia not hiring a little bit
of from Hillary about what has motivated
her position here I think we are living
in a time warp yes 25 years ago 30 years
ago 40 years ago you could plausibly
argue that the United States was quote
propping up the Saudi government the
world has changed since those days I
know you haven't worked in the
government since then but the Saudis
don't see us as propping us up them up
anymore I've got a question I came in
here originally full-motion and you've
given a argument based quite substantial
and human rights and abuse of human
rights within Saudi Arabia yet you put
them in the same bracket as Hillary is
it in the country like Israel which is
one of the only countries who have gay
rights and women's rights far beyond
most of the Arab countries and secondly
how far do you think their abuse of
human rights would go should we get out
of bed with Saudi Arabia okay thank you
there was somebody else with the
microphone I think there's another form
of apartheid in Saudi Arabia that hasn't
been mentioned as pernicious as gender
apartheid which is religious apartheid
no no one has mentioned what happens to
Christians in that country over the
course of the evening I've been rather
persuaded by the rail politique of James
Rubin and Sir Alan but something makes
me stopped into before siding with them
that how can one relate to a country
that transgresses human rights to that
appalling degree really and and when we
look at South African which was a
reasonable comparison I think finally
South Africa was brought into the
community of nations
Saudi Arabia doesn't belong there and
now that is here and for that matter
Jamie briefly and panel do keep your
responses fairly tight you're right
there are serious freedom impinges of
the rights of people too
to go to church to express their
religion in Saudi Arabia as there are in
all the things that Mona said religion
is one of the things she didn't say she
said most of the others the question
always is what do you do about it and I
think where Alan really put the question
to our opponents is how do you improve
things and I've been part of this debate
with the US government when we went at
this question of how do you improve
things and it's a difficult subject do
you cut off ties do you cut off trade do
you try to get them expelled from
organizations do you shine a light and I
think in the end our best chance of
making change is to use the tools of the
US government to shine a light on the
problems all right just very this isn't
so hard in terms of what to do if we
didn't have a privileged relationship
with Saudi Arabia and with Israel and we
had better relations full-range
relations with every country with every
regional relevant actor they would
balance themselves we wouldn't have to
constantly intervene with hyeyeon
galleries they would balance themselves
the human rights abuses wouldn't get
worse the red haired corner has to
answer the white haired corner
accusation that I didn't do my job my
job here Allen was not to give
alternatives or to give advice to the
West my job was to answer the motion
which was the West should get out of bed
and I think I gave very clear reasons
why the West should get out of bed and I
think that it's very important to
remember that when it comes to Saudi
Arabia it's not just Islam it's as my
debate partner has mentioned are the
opponents of the Saudi royal family
there is also a massive liberal
population in Saudi that is always
ignored and they have to be considered
in this because it's not just a bunch of
crazy lunatic fundamentalists that the
Saudi regime has helped be the only
alternative the Saudi regime like other
regimes in the region actively oppose
any alternative but the lunatic fringe
to scare you who's got the microphone
yes go ahead please I've got a very
clear picture of what the opposition are
proposing we you know what we what we
should vote against but what does voting
for this motion look like what are we
supposed to do I'm getting the
impression that the
the argument I'm hearing is this has
condemned the house of saud for all of
its human rights to rights abuses that
sounds like a different motion so what
what is it we'd be voting for okay all
right can I go to the top tier there's
somebody there yeah yeah hi there this
is this state is more of a comment it's
why are we not talking about the big
elephant the big white elephant in the
room which is oil why is Saudi Arabia
globally relevant when Yemen and Sudan
isn't for example okay thank you
I'm a former oil trader before I was a
politician I was in the oil business and
so much rubbish has spoken about oil I
have to say first thing I'd say is if
you don't like it try living for a week
without it and you won't be able to but
the United States is more or less now
self-sufficient in oil so the
significance of producers as a
geopolitical partner are much diminished
but it is the world you have to keep
their oil supplies going it's not
uniquely a US or a UK relationship with
the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia they need
the money from the oil they don't need
the oil rights very briefly it's a
critically important question because
the what's put out there all the time is
that we need the Saudis for oil that's
the bargain is that we need the Saudis
for oil here it's not just south it's a
Saudi problem this is where the
complicity the dysfunctionality of the
relationship of being in bed with the
Saudis is so important we work with we
collaborate with the Saudis to use oil
as a weapon against other countries
whether it's Iran to impose sanctions on
Iran whether it Russia to impose
sanctions on Russia if it weren't for
that if we weren't using oil as a weapon
collaborating with the Saudis there
would be much more diversity of supply
the u.s. silk doesn't really sound you
will hear rubbish talked about oil you
have just heard
let's go to the floor please let's take
several questions or comments yes we
don't you respect to the s side I think
you're going to take the question
seriously you have got to think about
what happens next so if we get out of
bed with a house of saud who are they
going to turn to instead but there are
270 weapons and support on President
Putin looks like a good bet and with his
well-known record on gay rights and
ethnic minorities that may not be an
improvement so I think we have got to
consider that thank you this lady here
in the yellow I got a little bit
suspicious whenever I hear anybody talk
about shades of grey for lots of reasons
but mainly because it sounds like the
sort of thing you say before you
purchase the hide principles the
greatest steps forward in humanity have
happened when people have put assured
sides shades of grey and decided that
things are important and I also think
that it's a very unfair burden to place
on the proposition to come up with some
alternative version and so I would push
the burden back on the opposition and I
would and I would say how how bad would
it have to get in Saudi Arabia before
you decided it was worth getting out of
bed with
I think the opposition have made a very
skillful case but I think they've
created rather a false choice getting
out of bed with Saudi Arabia's not the
same as not engaging at all with Saudi
Arabia and when we're asked what does
this mean could I suggest what it might
mean one we shouldn't sell arms of a
very sophisticated kind on the scale we
do massively arms that Saudi Arabia
doesn't need and can't actually probably
use properly secondly we shouldn't have
stood idly by without any condemnation
when the Saudis move troops into Bahrain
I don't think James Rubin is right to
say the United States was not supporting
the stance that Saudi Arabia has taken
in Yemen it is not necessary to be
completely disengaged from Saudi Arabia
simply by getting out of bed we
shouldn't be aiding them so much and
their foreign policy
and you'd be very clear the United
States supports the Saudis in Yemen okay
so please take that into consideration
look you can imagine a hell on earth and
the place that comes closest to that
right now is that little place where
Isis controls part of Syria and part of
Iraq where people are burned to death in
front of the cameras where people's
heads are cut off in rows on the beach
because they come from a different
religion the hell on earth and the
Middle East exists it's in the ISIS
portion of Iraq and Syria and so I'm
happy to worry about how bad Saudi
Arabia could get some day I've been
there I can assure you it's not that bad
as as Isis and I'd like to focus as one
does in life one has priorities and the
priority right now is to defeat those
extremists who now have a place a state
we always said after 9/11 imagine if a
terrorist organization had a state
within which to plan and organize and
they have visas to come back to Europe
and the United States we're gonna be
having a debate if we don't deal with
this 10 years from go from now about why
we didn't stop Isis when we have to
change thank you thank you okay at the
back there the lady I have a comment I
actually don't think the United States
should be bad with anyone in the Middle
East I think that they should be
absolutely out of bed with anyone they
should be a credible broker of the truth
and they should actually regarding Isis
they should actually get the Saudis and
the Iranians to form an army to combat
Isis and that would put Saudi Arabia in
a better stance with the rest of the
world because my view of Saudi Arabia is
there there perhaps the largest sponsors
of terrorism in the world
all right this lady here yes I'm one I
want to address mr. Rubin 2016 is coming
real quick in America we have an inner
president and this man just probably is
could have helped in that area of the
world but chose not to because he's a
coward and he's totally inept but now
who do you think in 2016 has got a shot
and what do you think the situation is
if we get a Republican president which
I'm hoping and begging for you would
think would happen with a relationship
with America with Saudi Arabia yes okay
so who do you think is going to have a
relationship with Saudi Arabia out of
the possible presidential candidates one
more and then we'll go to the panel yep
hi I'm a student who lived in Saudi
Arabia and I just like to ask both sides
what would happen to America if they got
out of bed with Saudi Arabia
well West is a lot bigger than America
all right let's let's let's take a
responsive from the audience
Mona I've come to relieve you yeah over
and over I've heard many of you keep
asking myself and Hillary what is the
alternative what are you proposing that
is not the motion here the motion
instead you should be asking our
opposition how her staying in bed and I
think the West not in the West is
definitely not the US I mentioned Canada
I will remind you of Sweden where the
Foreign Minister was prohibited from
addressing the Arab League because she
had the nerve to bring up the terrible
human rights record of Saudi Arabia you
should be asking your position how has
decades and decades of colluding with
the Saudi regime helped ordinary Saudis
it hasn't it has made it almost
impossible to oppose the regime because
the regime knows that the West will
allow it to get away literally with
murder and with various human rights
violations so it's the responsibility of
our opposition to show you how this
cowardly foreign policy of constantly
colluding with the Saudis helps ordinary
Saudis
not eight decades eight decades of an
alliance between the West and Saudi
Arabia City chief question does hang on
what would replace them if they were to
be displaced the idea that the West is
some kind of cohesive grouping is I
think impractical what let me put it
this way the best advice I ever received
as a politician was if you're really
stuck find a way of blaming the French
but but the real point is that it's just
so easy as I said in my opening remarks
to sit in your armchair and say they've
had they're bad they're bad we're gonna
have nothing to do with them but it does
matter in the real world what then would
follow and the danger is that the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia turns into Isis
plus plus if you want that good on you
well done congratulations you'll pretend
that you were never here tonight okay
thanks Jaime Rubin and I'll come to
grief in the impacts of law just very
briefly I think the question was how
Saudi Arabia relations that you might
play in the yes I don't think there's a
big difference between Democrats and
Republicans about Saudi Arabia except to
the extent it relates to another subject
which is the Iran agreement and there
there are big differences but I think
it's fair to say that on the right
there's great anger at the Saudi Arabia
because of 9/11 and all the long term
funding of Wahhabi ISM and on the left
there's great anger because of all the
things that Mona said we don't get to
decide what kind of government people
have and and frankly that's been the big
loser of the Arab Spring democratic
values in the Middle East have taken a
hit because of the direction things have
gone pro nents of a dysfunctional
relationship with Saudi Arabia
constantly put out the boogeyman either
that the alternative is Isis ignoring
the fact that it's us Saudi
collaboration that first created the
Taliban then al Qaeda and now Isis
they put forward the alternative
boogeyman that there that there's
there's no alternative because there's
no way to engage a government in a
normal way we have to have a
dysfunctional relationship with them
where we ply them with eighty billion
dollars in weapons
to have a normal relationship well that
doesn't work around the world that's not
what's real foreign policy that's not
realpolitik what the opposition is
arguing is again
I now have the results of this
intelligence squared debate
I need a drumroll and the motion of
course that remind you all was the West
should get out of bed with the House of
Saud this is how the audience here has
voted after they've heard our speakers
and put questions to them for the motion
this side forty seven percent against
the motion this side forty nine percent
[Applause]
the don't know has gone down
dramatically from forty percent to four
percent so the audience there in Cadogan
Hall is with you against the motion you
also have had the biggest swing in the
favor of your argument
[Applause]
well very very interesting debate result
there congratulations to to this side
our thanks to all the speakers on our
panel the audience here at Cadogan Hall
in London and of course you wherever you
are watching this debate on BBC while TV
thank you very much indeed to
intelligence squared for making this
debate possible from me Zainab Adama and
all of the team thank you very much good
bye
[Applause]
[Applause]